okay so parasite follows the kim's who
end up infiltrating a wealthy elite
family under the guise of being
something they're not they're very much
parasitic people and this is hinted at
early on in the movie when we're first
introduced to them living in a basement
home we catch them in despair as they
realize that the person whose wifi
they'd been piggybacking off of had now
put a password on it however they
managed to pick up a signal in the
bathroom which means they can use the
free wi-fi from a coffee shop just down
the road they are very much parasites of
that wi-fi connection but the
similarities to a lowly life form don't
stop there we catch them folding pizza
boxes and they're very much in a
symbiotic relationship with a fast food
company this company requires a lot of
hands in order to do this but they don't
have the money to take on full-time
members of staff the kims don't do the
job properly and a quarter of the boxes
are unusable but the pizza company have
no other option which the kim somewhat
play upon not long after we watch
workers spraying pesticide in the street
and this is commonly used to kill bugs
and parasites it blows into their
basement home and this basement home of
course foreshadows some of the reveals
that we get in the movie after realizing
their phones have been cut off chungsuk
asks her husband can take what his plan
is but we never really get an answer
later on in the film kytek reveals that
it's better not to have a plan as plans
always go wrong and if you don't have
one then nothing bad can happen this
somewhat juxtaposes the end of the film
in which his son kiwi says he's making a
plan to go to university become
successful and then buy the house so
that his father can finally come out of
the basement i've seen a lot of back and
forth over the film namely whether this
ending is something that happens and
we'll discuss why it's pretty bad news
for the family later on in the video now
with the success of squid game i thought
i'd revisit some korean classics that
really show why the country is currently
leading the way when it comes to tv
shows and movies they just seem to be
adept at creating outstanding original
stories that are layered with social
commentary and parasite is no different
the oscar-winning film is filled with
hidden details things you missed and a
lot of clues that hint towards the
eventual reveals that i want to break
down in this video if you enjoy it we'd
massively appreciate you showing some
respect and also don't forget to
subscribe as we do breakdowns like this
each and every day now the movie is
directed by bong joon ho who actually
got the idea for the film because he
worked as a tutor before he started
making movies bong joon ho was actually
recommended for this job by his
girlfriend and he said that he used to
imagine getting all his friends jobs
within the household bong joon ho very
much said that being staffed like this
is the only way that people on the
opposite side of the class system would
ever actually meet and throughout the
film there's lip service paid to how
people shouldn't cross the line the idea
of recommendations is fine within the
household to a point but it asks the
bigger question of what happens when
this model is used in more high profile
jobs the director stated that if a
politician gets a family member or a
friend or a job in a high position then
they probably aren't qualified for it
and we end up with a society where our
leaders aren't able to do the jobs that
they're appointed to it holds a lot of
meaning to it and again asks the
question should people cross the line
now the conversations about crossing the
line often come from the wealthy
family's father nathan park who
constantly remarks throughout the movie
that he likes people who don't do it
lines are actually used throughout the
film and if you look at the window edges
here you'll notice that it creates a
line between the two characters that we
see on screen on one side is the
housekeeper whilst the other is the
wealthy wife of nathan and the former
crosses the line in order to clap and
wake the other one up it's very subtle
and moments like this are placed
throughout the movie in which lines and
camera movements are used to show when
characters cross from one side to the
other nathan actually says that he
doesn't mind if the driver has sex in
his car what he's angry about is him
crossing the line into the back seat
this is of course a metaphor for the
social and class system within the
country and it's very deeply layered now
park's company is actually called
another brick and this is a nod to the
song another brick in the world by pink
floyd this shows how he views his staff
as all being just another brick in the
wall walls are designed to not fall down
if one brick is removed and therefore he
just views people as expendable whenever
he's talking about his staff we never
see him saying anything positive and
when discussing the first housekeeper he
states that she always used to eat
enough for two this hints towards the
reveal at the midpoint of the film in
which we find out that her husband
actually lived in the secret basement in
the home's bunker and that she'd sneak
him meals when nathan is introduced we
can see the lights turning on as he
walks up the stairs and as he gets to
the top of them they then turn off this
is revealed as being carried out by
ginsei who lives in the basement and
operates them as a sign of respect now
kiwi gets the job after his friend who
works as a tutor for the parks says that
he's going to be studying abroad again
kiwi is parasitic in nature as he only
latches onto the family because he uses
someone else who passes him onto them
kiwi's friend presents the kims with a
mystical rock that is said to bring
wealth to the family and it's clear that
they believe it has somewhat of a power
in it however later on when the kim's
home floods we find the rock floating
which indicates that it's hollow not
only does this explain why kiwi was able
to survive the blow to the head but it
also hints to us the hollow promises
that the rock carries with it upon
making it to the house kiwi slowly
brings his family across as they oust
the current staff so that they can take
their place the movie is filled with
staircase imagery and bong joon-ho
stated that he puts so many in the movie
as they represent people traveling
upwards through the class system stairs
are pretty much featured in almost every
scene in the film and it hammers home
the idea that there's a divide between
the upper and lower class people one of
the most heartbreaking moments comes at
the midsection when the family have to
return home to their flooded house and
we watch as they wander down the stairs
after living the high life whilst the
parks were away kitay grabs his wife's
silver medal and silva is of course
second place which gives a nod to how
they're very much second-class citizens
something that you might not have
noticed is that the table within the
park's home also looks like a staircase
itself and we watch as it ascends from
the bottom to the top when kiwi first
goes to the house we can see that there
are eight chairs at the dining table
later on after the housekeeper and her
husband are locked in the basement there
are two added and this represents the 10
people making up the three families in
the home the house is absolutely
incredible and we learned that it was
designed by a man named nam goong this
is actually a nod to the character nam
goong from snow psa another of bong joon
ho's work nam goong designed the train
in the film and he was played by sung
kang ho who also plays keytake in this
movie also apologies for the
pronunciation in this video i know these
aren't exactly how the names are said
and i'm not doing the english speakers a
favor right now by butchering them so
badly but i promise i'm trying i'm just
a terrible terrible youtuber now at one
point in the film the daughter of the
parks to high talks about how her
brother the song is faking the way he
acts so that his mother views him in a
positive light this is brushed aside by
kiwi who is of course doing the exact
same thing he even instructs her to use
the word pretend twice in her english
exam and this happens at a point in
which both he and his sister are
pretending to be people they're not as
for his sister it's through her we learn
of the song's trauma namely how he saw a
ghost when he was younger he was eating
birthday cake when a strange man
appeared in the house and this triggered
a seizure at the end of the film we
watch his birthday party once more in
which the man returns and this earlier
scene sets up why things happen the way
that they do hilariously her mother
chung suk says that she'd be a great con
artist if she wanted to be but she very
much is in this movie it's just clear
they don't see themselves as doing
anything illegal now the parks are
played as the innocents in the film but
they have their own prejudices and
snubbery that sort of shows how they
view the lower class people nathan can't
stand the smell of the poor and he
remarks that mr kim has an oda that's
just like the underground this has its
own subtext too as the underground is of
course something that's beneath the
surface and one must travel down some
stairs in order to get there mrs park
also isn't that innocent either and
though she says she will pay kiwi more
than they agreed to after his first
session you can actually catch her
skimming off the top and taking away
some of the cash that she was initially
going to give him i believe that this
was actually the salary that she paid
kiwi's friend but she realized that she
could get away with paying him less so
just decided to take it out after they
return home from the camping trip she
asks for ramdun to be made which is a
combination of two meals typically loved
by kids the meal is popular among super
and rich but mrs park can't have a son
eating what she views as common a food
so she has sirloin steak added to it in
order to ramp it up now keytake has some
of my favorite scenes in the film and a
lot of them are laced with subtext he
becomes the family driver and the
relationship that he has with the parks
is very symbolic there is sort of a
barrier between the front and seat of
the car and he is pretty much driving
and doing all of the work whilst they
relax in the back there's even a point
where mrs park is sat putting her feet
up while ski take drives the car and she
chats away to her friends whilst he has
to sit in silence it's very much
painting out the metaphor that the ones
doing the work are silenced and they
have to put all the effort into things
whilst a wealthy elite can just relax
and put their feet up they are very much
living a completely different life to
the poor and not subjected to the same
issues that they are mrs park at one
point says that the rain was a blessing
as it meant that they could return home
from their camping trip however it
completely devastates the kim household
and means that they have to sleep in a
gym along with the rest of the poor
there are some amazing accompanying
shots such as the housekeeper vomiting
in the basement toilet whilst the sewage
vomits out of the toilet at the kim's
mrs park also chooses clothes from her
vast and expansive wardrobe whilst the
poor have to fight over them in a gym
after their homes are devastated we also
catch kiwi texting the next day and his
hand has an imprint on it due to holding
the rock through the night now this
reveal at the midpoint of the movie is
pretty breakneck and the entire feeling
of the film shifts after the doorbell
rings this actually happens at the exact
midpoint of the film and it was also
exactly in the middle of the script we
see the cut security camera and this
also happens in the scene that comes at
the midpoint of the movie however it
also sets up the ending as it explains
how ketake is able to escape into the
house without being caught he very much
takes the position of jensei who is one
of my favorite characters for all the
wrong reasons we learn that he's in
hiding because he's in so much debt due
to his company taiwanese castella in the
movie there's a line about how kitake
was a driver for them and there is
potential that he was somewhat
instrumental in his downfall either way
it's such a creepy betrayal how we learn
that he's been sending messages through
morse code which key take also does at
the end of the movie in order to relay
something to his son now the tragedy is
that these families could work together
and live this life comfortably for a
long time however the kims are very much
people that will climb to the top of the
stairs and kick other people down so the
entire thing is blown open when jon say
escapes he has spent years in the
basement and upon exiting it we can see
that his pupils are massively dilated he
comes out stabs kyung and then chung-suk
stabs him in retaliation however when
it's clear that nathan doesn't care
about their daughter or her death plus
the the winching at his smell that
triggers him he takes stabs him too he
then retreats into the basement and we
learn that he's lying low there
indefinitely his son is arrested and
along with his mother they're found
guilty of fraud kiwi goes to look at the
house and this shot is actually a
reference to a painting by peter doyg
called the architect's home in the
ravine kiwi makes a plan to become rich
so that he can buy the home and finally
embrace his father as he leaves the
basement just before this he puts the
rock in some water and it doesn't float
showing that this is indeed a fantasy
his plan is to work hard and get rich
after going to uni which if you're over
the age of 30 then you know that's
probably not as easy as it sounds now
whilst people have gone back and forth
over whether the scene will come true or
not unfortunately if you stay for the
credits then you'll know that it
probably won't happen the song that
plays over them is actually sung by choi
wu shik who plays kiwi in the movie in
it he pretty much sings the tale of what
happens after the film namely how he
gets a job doing back-breaking manual
labor he says that it would take over
500 years to earn enough money to buy
the house but it is quite upbeat and he
thinks that he will do it whether it
happens or not we don't know but it ends
this amazing film and obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on it in the
comments below if you enjoyed the video
then don't forget to subscribe
and i hope you click the thumbs up too
if you want some meals to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
all the hidden details in squid game
which will be linked on screen right now
it's one of the best videos we've ever
made so definitely go and watch it if
you enjoyed this if not then thank you
for checking this one out and sitting to
the end i hope you have a good week and
you take care of yourself i've been paul
you've been the best i'll see you on the
next one peace
you